-Guys, whenever I get some
downtime here at the show,
I like to go on Instagram and
I scroll through all the photos.
And one thing I've noticed is
that, a lot of times,
two people will write
the same exact caption,
but the pictures they post
will be completely different.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for "Picture This."
-♪ Picture this, picture this,
picture this ♪
♪ Yeah, picture this ♪
-Alright, let's take a look at
this first example.
It's from Macy's and
the U.S. Justice Department.
-Really?
-Yeah, they both wrote, "He sees
you when you're sleeping,
he knows when you're awake."
Macy's posted
a picture of Santa.
The Justice Department posted a
picture of Mark Zuckerberg.
-Oh.
-You see?
-Wow.
-This next one is from Disney
and Bill de Blasio.
They both wrote, "Take a trip
with characters
from another galaxy."
Disney posted a picture of their
new "Star Wars" cruise.
Bill de Blasio posted a picture
of the F Train at 2:00 a.m.
-Wow.
-Where's the lie?
-No, he wouldn't...
Here's one from
Netflix and Rite Aid.
They both wrote, "Still going
strong, four years later."
Netflix posted a picture of
the new season of
"Stranger Things."
Rite Aid posted a picture of
the ChapStick
that's been in your coat pocket
for the last four years.
-Hey!
-Next one is from
the National Parks Service
and Target.
-Wow!
-They both wrote, "Careful, this
could explode at any moment."
National Parks Service posted a
picture of Old Faithful.
Target posted a picture
of Pillsbury Crescent Rolls.
Yeah, that's...
They're frightening.
-Whoo-hoo-hoo!
-You know it's coming, too.
-Yeah.
-You're just like...
-[ Giggles ]
-Yeah, he laughs at you.
-He laughs. Laughs at you.
-Yeah.
The Pillsbury Doughboy doesn't
laugh with you.
-With you. No.
-He laughs at you.
-Did not know that.
-No.
[ Both giggle ]
"You son of a bitch."
Hey!
No need!
-Next up, this one's from two
HBO Max subscribers.
They both wrote, "I was going to
get rid of HBO Max,
but then I saw this."
One subscriber posted a picture
of the "Harry Potter" reunion.
Other subscriber posted
a picture of
his friend's HBO Max password.
We can't sign off now.
This last one is from
Adele and your uncle.
They both wrote, "It was an
overwhelming journey,
but I'm glad it's out."
Adele posted a picture of her
new album, "30."
Your uncle posted a picture of
his belly after
Thanksgiving dinner.
That's all the time we have for
"Picture This."